the James Charles Tati Westbrook drama
continues as Nikita dragon gets involved
a lot of people try to slay the dragon
but she can't be sane
just days after Tati recorded a nearly
hour-long video about ending her
friendship with James get off your high
horse and have some respect and after
James apologized to his bestie of three
years to Tatia James Westbrook
I'm sorry for everything that is going
on everything that I have put you
through over the past few weeks Nikita
is now trying to help James out Nikita
went on Twitter posting these
screenshots of text messages trying to
prove James hadn't pre-plan to work with
Dante's rival hair vitamin brand yeah
remember this all seemingly started over
supplements James promoted sugar bear
hair vitamins Tati owns a halo Beauty
vitamins I was just like so gutted and
it wasn't specifically just about
vitamins or about halo but it was just
about being lied to and feeling
disrespected and you know James Charles
he had nine days after Coachella to talk
to me James claimed he partnered with
the other company after they provided
him with security at Coachella arguing
it wasn't a real endorsement deal that
leads us to Nikita's screenshots in one
James is asking Nikita if she could text
someone from sugar bear hair to get
artist passes at Coachella in another a
group chat the brand agrees and asks for
James's number but Ike's
things don't seem to add up as tea spill
posted a different screenshot where
James said sugar bear hair reached out
to pin fans also seem to think Nikita's
texts are a little fishy they still
think James is a snake
it's gonna be like the downfall of your
career don't do it listen I I dealt with
a lot of snakes in 2018 and that's where
I'm gonna leave her in the aftermath of
this whole fiasco
James has lost million
of YouTube subscribers and followers
including Miley Cyrus and Kylie Jenner
this ego is so big that he will think
that everything is about him I
absolutely loved James Charles my
husband loved James Charles he had an
open door here in my home anytime he had
a problem any time he needed life advice
business advice you know we were we were
here for him I've promoted him I have
supported him and it's safe to say his
and aunties friendship can't be repaired
she criticized his off-camera behavior
too doubling down in some Instagram
comments about what she said in her
video oh my god you tried to trick a
straight man into thinking he's gay yet
again and somehow you're the victim I'm
so disappointed in myself that I ruined
our relationship but that did mean so
much to me even if I didn't do the best
job of showing it all the time I wish
that I could say this is the last time
that I would make a mistake but I won't
be I'm just handling it day by day and
try my absolute best and of course
learning for my mistakes and it's a
learning process there's no guide book
on how to do this it's just be yourself
and hopefully people are there for the
ride
you